there are many things that need to be
done in these communities and and many
people whether it be the government or
non-profits or or others need to play
their their their role I'm just focusing
on one sliver of it which I think is an
important and catalytic sliver uh which
is creating more jobs and more economic
growth and more places uh as I do think
that's one way at least I can contribute
to trying to knit together a very
divided country and giving the country
at the best possible shot of continuing
to be the most Innovative
entrepreneurial nation in the world even
as we're seeing the globalization of
Entrepreneurship and uh and and uh
there's reasons to be concerned that
maybe this next 250 years won't be as
strong as the last 250 years but rather
than just sit back and and complain
about it or worry about it I figured
I'll do at least my part to do something
about it and for me that's focused on on
Rise of the rest
foreign
[Music]
it is my pleasure and privilege to
Welcome to the podcast one of America's
nay the world's great entrepreneurs
founder of AOL Revolution and Rise the
rest and best-selling author of the
brand new book The Rise of the rest how
entrepreneurs and surprising places are
building the American dream Steve case
welcome Steve Andrew great to be with
you we've been on this journey together
for a decade and it's great to continue
the journey continue the dialogue heck
yeah man uh so you and I became friends
when we were both on the national
advisory Council for Innovation
entrepreneurship that you were the chair
of we're both presidential ambassadors
of global entrepreneurship we hung out
in Cincinnati Ohio uh when we were both
there for a mayor's Summit and you are
singular in American Life in my opinion
as being one of the uh the I'm gonna use
the the b word one of the billionaires
entrepreneurs who's who's championed
cities that really were not hubs for
Innovation or entrepreneurship or growth
companies and you freaking picked up
that Banner uh now about a decade ago
when you were leading startup America
um what the heck got you into the
revitalizing America business well first
of all when you're saying you're talking
I was just thinking
I was at a rise the rest event in DC
the week you resign from Venture for
America
and we were walking together into the
event and I said what will you are you
going to do next and there was a long
pause and you looked at me said
I think I'm going to run for president
Universal basic income and I was like
wow I had no idea so I think I was one
of the first people in the country other
than perhaps your your family to know
what you were up to and I give you great
credit for jumping into that race and
obviously getting a lot of traction and
elevating you know that that issue of
really trying to deal with a you know
pretty significant uh income inequality
issue uh so but going to your going to
your question uh I got into this you
know like many things a little bit by
accident it was not something I was you
know kind of intending to do and it goes
back to exactly your introduction when I
was asked to lead that National advisory
Council and Innovation entrepreneurship
I think it was 11 or 12 years ago
um uh I like most people were a little
skeptical what is this you know kind of
going to do you know a lot of things in
DC groups come together write reports
and they sit on shelves and so I I I'm
sure like you were a little skeptical
but we did get some traction and and
some of the things that we we focused on
uh like you know trying to get more
Capital entrepreneurs trying to
celebrate entrepreneurs uh led to things
like the White House startup America
effort that President Obama asked me to
lead and then led to things like the
jump starting our business startups act
jobs act which passed about 10 years ago
and to me uh that whole process and that
series of of of things opened my eyes to
something that I hadn't fully understood
number one was that most jobs in this
country are created by new companies
small business is very important big
business is very important but new
business company under five years is
really most important I didn't fully
appreciate that and I also didn't fully
appreciate that uh Venture Capital uh
was basically going to a few cities that
over the last decade 75 percent of
venture capitals gone to just three
states California Massachusetts and so
when you put those two things together
it doesn't take you know you have to be
a rocket scientist to say okay most of
the new jobs are created by new
companies and most of the successful new
companies that really create lots and
lots of jobs do raise Venture Capital
but venture capital is overwhelmingly
just going to a few States you know we
have a problem here and how do we
address that how do we level the playing
field how do we create more companies
and more places that can create more
jobs in more places and so that's LED
this to launch the rise rest bus tours
eight years ago we did a series of those
tours visited you know 40 44 cities that
led us about five years ago to take the
next step of of launching the rise rest
fund to back entrepreneurs so far we've
backed 200 companies and 100 different
cities and that led more recently to
writing this book because after spending
this decade trial in the country I
thought the stories of these
entrepreneurs were remarkable the
renewal of these cities was was was both
surprising and gratify flying and I
didn't think it was a story that was
told most people do not realize what's
happening all these different cities so
that's a long answer to a short question
but that's how we got to now
I mean you say it so casually man but
that's 10 years of your life it's 10
years of work so it's been fun it's been
fun so you grew up I want to say in
Hawaii I believe you went to the same
high school that Barack Obama did but
then you also spent some time in the
midwest you live in the Virginia area
now so you're kind of I suppose from
different parts of America that are
giving you a different perspective
you're the chair of the Smithsonian I
believe which might be the most yeah
American institution that that there is
uh where do you think you got this
affinity for trying to uh have
opportunities arise in different places
well it's a good question I've reflected
on that even even writing the book and
you're right I did grow up in in Hawaii
my parents both were born and raised in
Hawaii so our family goes back there
over a hundred years I did go to uh high
school with uh President Obama I was
actually a senior when he was a freshman
so he didn't have classes together but I
do remember playing basketball with them
did you Haze him I'm kidding
no I didn't and I would say everybody in
the school uh probably had at best
modest expectations how we would both
turn out so I think we were positive
surprises uh in terms of what ended up
happening me too for what it's worth
the club
with low expectations and you know would
not have made the most likely to succeed
list by anybody in high school so when I
graduated from I did go to college in
Massachusetts and then my first job out
of college uh was in Procter Gamble in
Cincinnati Ohio and then my second job
was for Pizza Hut in Wichita Kansas
where I was a director of new pizza
development at the time was owned by
PepsiCo and then after a little bit of
time there I moved to the the northern
Virginia area outside of Washington DC
uh to join a startup that was doing
something I thought was pretty
interesting uh but that company failed
so I was kind of welcome to the world of
startups sometimes they work often they
don't but thankfully to the people I met
and I ended up starting America Online
AOL in in 1985 and that was certainly
the early days of the internet then only
three percent of people were online
they're only on an hour a week and for a
decade or so
uh you know the skepticism about whether
the internet would ever amount to
anything was pretty pretty strong but
eventually after about 10 years we kind
of we kind of broke through I do think
some of that to your question some of my
experience growing up in a place like
Hawaii living in places like you know
Ohio and and Kansas and and then
Virginia uh helped give me a sense of
these places and appreciation for these
place but also recognizing some of the
challenges in those places and also
starting uh and scaling uh AOL in
Northern Virginia I think
at the time there was no venture capital
in in Northern Virginia there were not
really any startups in in Northern
Virginia it was really a government you
know town because it was outside of you
know Washington DC and so it was a
struggle to raise you know Capital it
was a struggle to hire people it was a
struggle to get people to Believe in Us
and pay attention to us I think that
also helps inform uh you know my
thinking so that back story combined
with what I mentioned before you know my
eyes being opened a decade ago to some
of the both the problems we had but some
of the opportunities we have uh I I
think kind of led me on this path to say
well uh I do have you know the ability
to you know thankfully to kind of have
be a change agent uh rather than enter
politics like you did I want to focus on
policy
things like the jobs act Gene is
grateful and I also want to do what I
can to to to try to level the playing
field so the people and places that do
feel left behind have more of a shot and
the communities all across the country
can start creating jobs and being part
of the future and so that that's why I'm
so passionate about this work and that
led me to write the book to share some
of these these stories
yeah you and I intersected around 2011
2012 so I start Venture for America in
some ways from the opposite end which is
uh the talent spectrum that there was
this brain drain out of the Midwest and
the South to the coasts uh Wall Street
Consulting law and eventually Tech
um and so I thought look we should
create a pathway for enterprising
aspiring entrepreneurs to be able to
link up with startups in Detroit
Cincinnati Cleveland Baltimore New
Orleans Birmingham
um so I I started it in 2011 uh it was
around the same time you were turning
your sites this way one reason why I
admire you so much is that I did that
work for six and a half years uh and
um reading your book was such a joy
because I actually know a lot of the
people know a lot of the characters like
you had I got to see some of the
companies actually take flight over the
the last
um five or six years
and and uh one of the things you say in
your book which I thought was very very
powerful you said two things I'll
present them both to you um one you said
is that look government uh has a role to
play but it can't be government that
rejuvenates uh a lot of these
communities like there are other things
that have to be done
um and then the the second thing you say
is that
um that the lack of growth and
opportunity in different parts of the
country is driving disunity now these
are both things that I I agree with
and I I wanted to just unpack either or
both with you where I I totally agree
with you that the government
um even though I'm now you know
something of a political guy like I
don't think the government can do it all
and that there are all these other
pieces to the puzzle so like what do you
see as the primary engines outside of
government well first of all I I I I I
do and I talk about some of this in the
book I do think there is a role for
government both at the national level
and more of the the local level and so
things like the job deck 10 years ago
makes sense things like as part of the
chips and science act uh you're kind of
authorizing 10 billion dollars of
funding for regional hubs makes sense
things like in the uh in the inflation
reduction act some funding around
Climate Technologies to to accelerate
the investment in in sort of the
sustainability I think uh makes sense
trying to hopefully soon you know get
immigration reform so we can continue to
win with now a global battle for talent
makes sense and then at more terrible
state and local level having Governors
Focus Less on economic development as
being an effort to lure big companies to
move their headquarters or open a
factory more on launching new companies
someday some of which can become big
companies make sense and having Mayors
really focus on and celebrate what
entrepreneurs are doing uh you know make
sense so there are a lot of things that
that the government can and should do to
kind of set the table kind of set the
ground rules you know create a fertile
environment for Innovation and
Entrepreneurship to flourish everywhere
but uh ultimately does come down to the
entrepreneur where the idea ultimately
does come down to investors you know
backing and supporting that and that's
where the work you were doing with with
vfa on the on the talent side and what
we've been doing on the on the capital
side are critically important and as you
know completely you know linked that
part of the reason there has been a
brain drain and people growing up in
different parts of the country even
going to some of our great universities
in Michigan again or Ohio or
Pennsylvania or other places and then
leaving those places to go to places
like Silicon Valley is because there
wasn't much opportunity there and some
of that was because there wasn't much
investment Capital you know kind of
there so if you can
you know create more of a sense of
possibility and and have more Capital uh
that should slow The Brain Drain of
people leaving and create a boomerang of
people returning and there are a couple
things that have happened the last
decade that I think are super
encouraging we did a report with
pitchbook last year and in the last
decade 1400 new Venture firms have
started in Rise of the rest cities
meaning outside of San Francisco outside
of New York outside of us 1400. so now
there are Venture firms in many places
that didn't exist a decade ago and there
is a six-fold increase in investment
dollars going to these Rises rest cities
so we're making progress and we had made
steady progress in the last each of the
years in the last decade but clearly the
pandemic was a Tipping Point accelerant
in terms of more people deciding to move
to other places investors who suddenly
look at meet entrepreneurs via pitch
meetings being able you know to do that
so we're not trying to capitalize on
that I think this next five or ten years
people are going to be really surprised
by how many signifi companies some of
which I you know dozens of which
actually I profiled the book are going
to launch and scale in places that that
are going to surprise people I'm going
to create lots of jobs in Detroit I know
you're passionate about Detroit I was
there last week two companies we backed
there Shinola and stockx neither existed
10 years ago both now have more than a
thousand employees in Detroit which just
shows you what both are have significant
valuation so it shows you this is
possible it really is working we just
need to be intentional about not just
backing the same kind of people in the
same kind of places well you put your
money where your mouth is uh Steve where
the rise of the rest fund I believe it's
150 million you've been investing in
dozens of these companies maybe hundreds
and I'm going to share a story for
everyone that's good fun
um so people listening this probably
know the uh healthy food chain sweet
Greens in which you're an investor
um one of the meetings we had you hosted
Us in the sweet greens for dinner and
they're yeah it and it was like a fancy
sweet greens Meal which was delightful
and I think we even had a little Shinola
gift for us at the Tails and Irish right
next door
yeah so it was
um you know it was your vision come to
life uh and and that's one reason I I
admire you so much is that you know like
you don't talk about stuff you actually
just go out and do it uh and what you're
trying to do is cultivate the next
generation of doers around the country
your last book the third wave talked
about how you thought the biggest
opportunities were going to be this
Union between
mature uh Industries or maybe upstarts
in those Industries like agriculture or
Logistics as you detail in this book and
and then technology was going to wind up
uh being the enabler
um which made sense to me
um as someone who spent a lot of time in
these environments because each of these
cities typically has some kind of
industrial base that throws off
expertise
uh that is distinct to that Community
yeah totally agree and uh first of all
the funds we've now done two funds it's
a 250 million dollar fund so 300 million
dollars total we've backed 200 companies
in 100 cities and I did put my money
where my mouth is because I anchor each
of those funds but I also want to point
out that we got several dozen other
individuals who are prominent
entrepreneurs and investors to join us
on this so are some of our investors in
in the rise of res fund include Jeff
Bezos and Howard Schultz and Sarah
Blakely and and Tory Burch and and
Venture investors like John doerr and
Jim Breyer and private Equity folks like
Henry krabos and David Rubinstein I
hedge fund people like Ray dalio and
families around the country include the
Walton family the Koch family a lot of
people have joined us on this I want to
make make it clear that this isn't just
about me it's a team of people that's
trying to identify promising
entrepreneurs and back them in the in
these rise the rest uh you know kind of
cities but you're totally right this
issue of expertise that domain expertise
about particular sectors I think is
underappreciated in terms of what I
think will happen in this next you know
decade of of innovation as you know
these rise arrest cities there's some
advantages they have cost of living is
lower cost of operations lower if you're
able to raise a million dollars it might
go two or three times further than if
you're in San Francisco or New York so
those are advantages or also some
lifestyle Advantage many of these cities
and you know amenities that that people
like some for some family dynamics that
are encouraging for some tax time you
know incentives are are might be a a a
factor but perhaps the biggest factor is
exactly what you said the Strategic
value of being in that City and that was
different than what we've seen in the
last decade I'll just give you a couple
examples there's a company we backed in
Chattanooga Tennessee called Freight
waves that's building I built a platform
kind of like Bloomberg for the trucking
and Logistics industry I didn't know
this though we're there with our rise
bus but some of the biggest trucking
companies in the country are
headquartered in Chattanooga so if
you're building Bloomberg for truck
talking better to be in Chattanooga than
to be in Manhattan or Silicon Valley
another one that is interesting is a
company called acre Trader in Northwest
Arkansas in Fayetteville the founder of
that company Carter Malloy actually was
in San Francisco working for a hedge
fund in San Francisco when he came up
with the idea of acre Trader which is a
platform to allow people to invest in
Farmland uh he decided he'd be better
off being in Arkansas closer to the
farmers in order to convince Farmers to
put their Farms on his platform and so
he moved there and it scaled quite quite
significantly and again he thought an
advantage to be in Arkansas as opposed
to being in in in California so there
are more and more of these examples of
of entrepreneurs who are really
leveraging what's unique about their
City unique about their their region to
build companies that are going to be
advantaged because they're there as
opposed to whether it's been historic
which is kind of disadvantaged because
they're not in Silicon Valley they don't
have access to Capital they don't have
access to the the town and that's why I
think this Rises phenomena that's going
to really accelerate over the next
decade and that's why I wrote the book
because I really wanted people to be
aware of what's happening and have a
sense of where the puck was going
a reading about these companies was a
lot of fun some of them uplifting and
invigorating I loved the stories of uh
75f which is trying to keep Office
Buildings a certain temperature which by
the way is incredibly good for Energy
Efficiency in the climate I think
commercial buildings the fourth biggest
emitters or consumers of energy so if
you could eliminate the waste it's
incredible app Harvest which I believe
was an indoor farming company though
it's based in Kentucky where they're
experiencing job loss and coal miners
and you make the correct observation
that look when someone talks about
retraining in these environments there
is the open question retrain for what
retrain for which employer because when
you when you go to those communities
they used to have one employer let's say
a coal mine and then if you say hey guys
great great news we're going to give you
certificates and some something else
they'll look around and be like what am
I going to do with this certificate so
that the fact fact that a company like
app Harvest actually is making a farm
that can produce what was it 20 30 times
as much food as that that area of square
yeah Jonathan Webb started this company
just five or six years ago and we were
the initial seed investor has now scaled
up it's actually a public company uh and
I created more than 500 jobs in in this
area outside of Lexington Kentucky that
as you said really has struggled for the
last several decades with you know kind
of the decline of the coal industry
everybody knows about some of the
challenges and and that area known as
Appalachia so he's done a great job
doing it and part of his idea was we
need to create healthier fruits and
vegetables uh and so that the indoor
Greenhouse now the largest indoor
Greenhouse in the country uh allows you
to do that he and also he saw an
advantage to be in Kentucky because 70
percent of the U.S population is within
a 24-hour Drive of where they are so
they can get those fruits and vegetables
to the markets more more quickly than if
they're on one of the code and also from
a sustainability standpoint uses 90
percent less water so it's good kind of
in all respects and he took that idea
and and ran with it and that's an
example of a rise rest company launching
in a place that most people don't think
startups launch scaling to create
significant jobs and you say not just
jobs for coders but jobs for all kinds
of people and some of the other ones I
mentioned before like uh you know stockx
uh or Shinola simile have retrained Auto
Workers to be working in in their jobs
either manufacturing of things like
watches in the case of Shinola or doing
the authentication that stockx does when
when people use their platform to you
know to buy and sell good sneakers and
other kinds of goods they need to be
authenticated so they get sent to
Detroit and that's why they have 1500
employees now for stockx uh when it was
you know essentially zero when the you
know when the company started five six
years ago and those are jobs in Detroit
I remember when Greg was just hanging
out at his uh yeah they didn't have many
employees when I went through so as I
hear you about it yeah I but they're
phenomenal
I I was visiting Dan Gilbert at the time
we were talking about a bunch of things
uh in Detroit and he said I want to take
you downstairs to you know show you the
stockx thing and we actually went to the
basement of his building and it was Greg
and like a half a dozen other people
just trying to figure out you know what
what the build there in a couple years I
went back and they had a uh their own
building and and now as I said they have
1500 employees a multi-billion dollar
you know kind of valuation so it's been
a great investment for us uh you know
probably close to 100 x return so far uh
but also been a really positive
contributor in terms of of Detroit and
one of the many companies that's really
helping to renew and Revitalize uh
Detroit so it's a it's a great example
of of the rise of rest so that when I
started adventure for America I was
concerned about uh brain drain and also
what was going on with the culture and I
think you hit on something in your book
which was is to me in some ways the most
important struggle that's going on on is
that when that entrepreneur who started
app Harvest Jonathan was talking to high
schoolers in Kentucky and he's trying to
get them excited about environments in
their area excited about the possibility
um there is this sense of optimism and
can-do spirit that animates most
entrepreneurs uh and you characterize it
as the American Spirit which it
certainly has been for a long time but
there is this sense that that Spirit may
or may not be the same as it was like
there's this kind of creeping pessimism
um and
uh your approach to trying to remedy
that is to try and invest real money in
real companies uh around the country to
show people that these things can be
built which by the way I see as a very
top-notch uh approach
to try to rebuild the spirit of optimism
and Entrepreneurship but do you sense
the same things I do are you concerned
that the can-do spirit of America like
is wavering or is being challenged no I
share the concern and I think we have
you know unfortunately and you know well
uh kind of created this two Americas
where there's some people in some places
that are doing really well and excited
by what's happening and and kind of
leaning into the future with great
confidence and optimism and many people
indeed most people uh struggling and
feeling left out and left behind and
that clearly has played out as you saw
firsthand and even in our in our
politics so I understand that I also
understand
there's many facets to it uh but yeah
our decision was to focus on one facet
of it which is trying to close this
opportunity Gap trying to create more of
a momentum in these communities more
hope in these communities and part by
creating more jobs in these communities
and driving more economic growth in in
these communities and and by doing that
by backing new companies backing
entrepreneurs backing backing startups
and as as you mentioned uh and you know
we profiled I think it's 30 cities more
than 40 companies in this book it's it's
not just the usual tech companies are
these Tech enabled you know Innovations
across many different industry sectors
and many of these companies are of
course creating some management jobs and
some technology jobs but also a lot of
other jobs uh and you know and that's
why companies like app Harvest have 500
people or companies like uh stockx have
1500 people people and and reversing
that sense where the companies were in
Decline the jobs were in Decline
unemployment was going up you know good
paying jobs you know were going down you
know government maybe can play a role
certainly can play part of a role there
but ultimately I do believe it's it's
the private sector particularly the
entrepreneurs stepping up and starting
companies in these places that create
jobs and hope and opportunity in these
places and it's also worth pointing out
for your for your your listeners you
already know this but it's not just
about the jobs within these startups
Within These new companies there's a
ripple effect across the community for
every startup job there's five other
jobs in the community people building
houses people working in restaurants all
kinds of other jobs are created when you
have a rising Community conversely when
you have a declining Community you lose
all those jobs and that's why yep
Detroit went from being the leading
Innovation City a century ago to over 50
years last 50 years losing sixty percent
of its population and then going
bankrupt it went from being this magnet
for talent and creating the Auto
industry and all the related supply
chain companies and then also creating
the other related jobs in the in those
communities and then suddenly when
things reversed it went into kind of
kind of free fall so the reason Detroit
is back and what's happening versus when
you and I were first there a decade ago
the momentum in downtown Detroit is
quite palpable the buildings that were
mostly empty a decade ago are now mostly
full actually they're cranes building
new buildings to house some of the new
companies that have been launched that
is creating more opportunity in those in
a city like Detroit and we're seeing
this in the dozens of other cities that
we've we visited and invested in with
the with rise at rest so I does give me
an optimistic view of America I
understand the problems I understand the
challenges I understand why so many
people are angry frustrated left out
left behind but but I think part of the
answer has to be creating the
opportunities leading with new companies
leading with the industry of the future
not just doing that in a few places like
you know Silicon Valley or New York City
doing that all across the country I'm
super excited by what we've seen just in
the last few years it feels like the
momentum is building and things are
really going to accelerate over the over
the next years
[Music]
oh yeah you see impression now man
because uh I feel like Talon is spread
out and gone to all sorts of places that
you've been championing or investing in
for years so the the moment is
definitely uh arriving a couple of
chapters in your book are about the
nature of entrepreneurs where when you
showed up in these cities initially and
I by the way I showed up in a lot of the
same cities and we both had the same
experience which is if you had a table
of entrepreneurs they were mostly white
dudes
and so then you you're like hey we
should try to try and broaden this out
and and change this up
um and we so we we both know that there
are multiple obstacles for uh
entrepreneurs from different backgrounds
who are not uh let's say uh white men
um if you're a woman you have lower
access to mentors often lower access to
seed capital and Angel Investors the
odds of your being invested in by a
venture capitalist what are what are the
numbers on that you you must know the no
they're pretty they're pretty bad the
the if you look at uh you shift from
place in the in the city that we've been
talking about to people here's the three
statistics that you know should get your
attention number one women are 50 of the
population female Founders get less than
10 percent of venture capital uh number
Latinos are 19 of the population they
get less than two percent of venture
capital and black Americans are 13 of
the population and they get less than
one percent of venture capitals so this
is not just a problem around place with
most of the capital going to places like
you know California New York and
Massachusetts it's also about people so
we really need to level the playing
field for place and for people and make
sure everybody who has an idea has a
fair shot at creating a company a fair
shot frankly at the American dream and
and what we've been doing in these
cities is intentional as we as we come
to the cities and trying to reach out
understand the different aspects going
on in each community and make sure we're
we're in connecting with a diverse mix
of Founders even when we do pitch
competitions in the city we have a a
diverse mix of entrepreneurs pitching on
stage as a result of that intentionality
more than 40 percent of the Investments
we've made I mentioned earlier 200
investment to date our female Founders
or founders of color which still isn't
what it should be but quite a bit more
than you see with with traditional you
know Venture floods and there really are
terrific entrepreneurs in these cities
terrific entrepreneurs who come from
different different backgrounds that do
have different perspectives that can
imagine better ways to do things which
is you know all entrepreneurs do is see
a problem and turn into an opportunity
and you're more likely to see a problem
based on your the life you live and that
gives certain people advantages uh but
we we have to supplement that Insight
they have with the access to Capital
mentorship all the things you just
mentioned so they can take those ideas
and run with them and we can create a
more inclusive Innovation economy in
this country not just in terms of cities
but also in terms of people yeah I I
think that's one reason why there's a
sense that I have and so uh
fun fun anecdote maybe so you and I were
presidential ambassadors of global
entrepreneurship
um in the white house and I'm watching
HBO a number of weeks or months ago and
then a picture of you and me pops up but
it's not about you and me it's because
Elizabeth Holmes of fairness is also in
the picture and it's the documentary
about her I don't know experience I did
not see that
yeah so anyway if you watch a
documentary Steve like you and I make a
very brief Cameo because they have like
without guilt by association
no no I mean you know it was a blink and
you miss it for for us
um but I mean that passage of the
documentary was about how Elizabeth
Holmes was getting uh anointed and uh
and blessed and praised and then
meanwhile she was uh pulling a fast one
um and that that's not the only major
movie about I suppose like the
uh excesses of a particular entrepreneur
uh there is we crashed about wework
there's uh the one about uh Uber and
Travis kalanick
um even a number of years ago when you
and I were were uh working around the
country I think
um people viewed Mark Zuckerberg and
Facebook differently than they do now
like that there were there were a bunch
of things that have kind of turned
culturally and I think part of it is
because of what you and I just described
as well which is uh a lot of the the
figures I mean Elizabeth Holmes is a
woman obviously but a lot of the figures
are uh white men and there is like a a
sense that that the excesses of
Entrepreneurship are something to be uh
guard against which I'm sure you and I
agree with but to me entrepreneurship
like has
you know a hundred times more good than
not good baked into it like like it's
it's people trying to go and solve
problems and I uh felt like that's the
way people saw entrepreneurship X years
ago but then there's been this cultural
treatment over this last number of years
that that seems to be more dubious uh I
I don't know if you've picked up on any
of that or whether maybe you don't watch
the same TV I do I don't know
definitely some of that I think some of
it is uh while people in this country
generally have celebrated the work of
the Pioneers that you know kind of
create new product services companies
and and therefore you know kind of
celebrate entrepreneurs uh lately there
has been a backlash I think some of it
is over this wealth Gap uh that some of
these you know people being worth tens
of billions or in some cases even
several hundred billion dollars just
doesn't seem right and also some of the
Innovations have you know taken a turn
that concerns people you mentioned you
know Facebook social media I was a
Pioneer in that 35 years ago when we
launched America Online it was really
first and foremost about Community chat
rooms instant messaging things like that
and I always believed that one of the
great opportunities for the internet was
to you know kind of level the playing
field in terms of access to information
and ideas you know Commerce other people
Etc but uh and and things that have
continued since then like Facebook
Twitter Etc I think have largely been
positives but there's been a negative
there's been an unintended consequence
including the way some of the algorithms
are used which do help tend to elevate
you know the some of the you know the
you know angry voices and and uh and
also uh there's concerns about how
social media kind of works and how
people
both on the internet and with cable
television kind of living their own
filter bubbles don't really get exposed
to either sided issues yeah information
silos of course their own views you know
those silos so that that's been an
unfortunate you know part of it so I
think that's all led to uh a backlash
against uh uh some entrepreneurs a
backlash against uh technology kind of a
backlash against Silicon Valley which
doesn't really surprise me actually you
mentioned my previous book the third
wave six years ago I predicted there
would be a backlash against a Silicon
Valley I could see it I could see it
Brewing but what's happened in the last
couple years has been more than I would
have uh expected again I I go back to
what we talked about earlier I think one
way to address that is to recognize that
part of the reason people are mad is
because those entrepreneurs in places
like Silicon Valley are creating these
disruptive technologies that might be
celebrated in Silicon Valley but often
mean job loss in their own community in
their own family the technologies that
drive productivity yeah if you're a
random manufacturing worker in Michigan
you don't feel like you're benefiting
from that yeah yeah the the robotics
company that that's getting this big
valuation and making the entrepreneur
Rich doesn't seem like it's helpful to
you so of course there's going to be a a
backlash and and the way I look at it is
there's always going to be this March of
Technology this this it's it 100 years
ago 90 percent of us worked on farms now
it's two percent because technology
basically allowed you to grow more food
with fewer people that's actually a good
thing if you want to feed the world it
was a bad thing for people working on
Farm but thankfully we were smart enough
to retrain those people on farms to work
in factories and the Industrial
Revolution took over from the
Agricultural Revolution but as you know
it's what you've written about even why
you ran for president the transition
from the Industrial Revolution to the
digital revolution has not been as
smooth and at a dislocated a lot of a
lot of people and hurt a lot of
communities so again there's many facets
to that the one I chose to focus on was
well how do we reverse that instead of
job loss in communities how do we create
job growth in communities and the only
way to do it in my opinion the only
sustainable way to do it is to back new
companies some of which will fail but
some of which will end up being the
Fortune 500 companies of tomorrow
yeah thank goodness you are who you are
doing what you're doing Steve uh because
there's no one else doing what you're
doing I mean it's funny like you and I
have been on uh these parallel Journeys
over the last decade or so and then
Circa 2017 I I
I said you know what so Trump wins yeah
I mean you and I've been working in
these communities for years and when
Trump wins I was like whoa like you know
that this was a red flag for me
um and and I felt like I I had an
inkling as to why it was happening
because uh the opportunities were
slipping away in so many parts of the
country and so then I went off in my
direction and then you uh got on the bus
and went these communities uh and
uplifted entrepreneurs and invested in
them and did all these things one reason
it was so much you got on the bus Boston
Iowa and New Hampshire running for
president I got on the bus trying to
meet entrepreneurs all across the
country so we both both hit the hit the
road on on buses but approaching it from
a different different lens and vantage
point
yeah thank you for for that um I did
have a bus in Iowa and that that was the
only time in the campaign my kids
thought I was cool they had to come on a
bus they're like get on the bus
so we went down these parallel tracks
reading uh your book gave me some uh at
least glimpse into into your last five
years
what are you
um most excited about most concerned
about moving forward you're on your
second Rise of the rest fund you've
cataloged all these awesome
entrepreneurs
um like what what do you feel like is
the next challenge because you are the
quintessential entrepreneur where you're
just gonna keep on building growing
discovering learning uh and innovating
well you're kind to say that the way I
think about it is because back to what I
said earlier about uh my experience with
AOL and the internet the first decade
was hard you know we dealt with a lot of
skepticism a couple times we almost hit
the wall you had to go through layoffs
because we're running out of money uh
most people didn't believe in the idea
the internet seems crazy now but back
then people would say why do you think
people are gonna get on the internet and
you know why do you think people are
going to use email when they can just
pick up the phone and call somebody why
do you think somebody's gonna use
e-commerce do they really think they're
going to trust putting their credit card
into the internet with all kinds of
skepticism and that continued for a
decade and that you know made it as you
know a difficult first decade and then
suddenly the a Tipping Point in the next
decade it went from an idea that nobody
knew or cared about to everybody needed
to get connect and that's when AOL went
from a little company to a big company
and evaluation when we went public in
1992 as a first internet company to go
public with 70 million dollars eight
years later it's 160 billion dollars of
best performing stock of the decade so
to me that was a reminder that sometimes
revolutions happen in evolutionary ways
and sometimes if you persist uh
eventually you hit a Tipping Point and I
felt that in retrospect with the
internet the first 10 years were hard
the second 10 years things accelerated I
feel the same way about the rise of rest
I've been at this for a decade as you
mentioned it's you know it's been a hard
decade building out the foundation
trying to get people to believe in in
the idea of backing more people in more
places I think this next decade is when
we really slam down the accelerator and
accelerate backing more of these
entrepreneurs and more of these places
where we join with some of the coastal
investors to to back these these
companies and I think that's partly
because uh people investors now have
their eyes more open to the opportunity
to make money by backing these
entrepreneurs in these places and it's
helped Along by some some policy I
mentioned before including the
legislation that just passed Congress
those last few months that's going to
result in more of a focus on place-based
strategy than yelling the treasury
secretary a few weeks ago talked about
the need for place-based strategy
essentially the same things we've been
saying as it relates to uh to rise the
rest so we've made some progress in in
this last decade but I think the real
work is ahead so we'll keep you know
doubling down trying to figure out ways
to kind of extend our our our reach
extend our network uh back more people
more places get more capitals people
slow The Brain Drain people leaving
accelerate the boomerang of people
returning do what we can to create more
communities that are open to uh to to
supporting entrepreneurs and and and and
not you know not focused on the status
quo trying to lean into the future
that's my way I think of trying to
contribute to this country by trying to
do what I can to the from the prism of
being a investor and and maybe a private
sector evangelist and occasionally a
policy kibitzer uh to try to have some
uh you know some some impact and oh by
the way we started this conversation by
talking about us both being on nacy the
national advisory Council on Innovation
entrepreneurship I'm back doing that
again you know when Gina
secretary she she asked for you know
several recommendations of what to do
and one of them was focused on more
Regional expansion so the regional hubs
are part of that and the other was to
restart that and they see you know kind
of group uh which had had kind of died
doing the Trump Administration so she
agreed to restart it but the deal was I
had to charity again so I'm now coaching
that's what happened Steve you you
suggested Ohio State University exactly
be careful what you suggest but I'm back
in there focusing on on some of the key
priorities of the country from an
innovation in perspective including
making sure this Regional Hub investment
goes well including trying to make sure
we're doubling down as a country on some
of the industries of of the future so
you know a little bit of policy
continued focus on philanthropy
including the the work you mentioned as
chair of the Smithsonian but most of my
focus is on expanding Revolution trying
to help the rest rise trying to help
entrepreneurs navigate some of the
policy challenges which I think are
going to create opportunities in a lot
of sectors and and this coming decade
thank goodness for you Steve putting in
10 years of work and then saying like
hey now we're gonna reap some some
rewards over the next 10 years most
people don't think in in those time
frames uh but but that's the way you
operate and you're changing the lives
not just of these entrepreneurs and the
people that they'll employ in the 5x
people that will be positively impacted
because they'll have jobs in their
communities but you are rekindling the
spirit of Entrepreneurship in
communities that need it uh some of
which may have lost it and you say in
your book that you think that's one of
the paths to Unity and I couldn't agree
more if you had a prosperous culture and
way of life in more parts of the country
then instead of being subject to you
know by fighting and blaming that you'd
actually look up and say okay what are
the real problems and how can we solve
them I agree I agree again I'm not
saying it's the the magic bullet there
are many things that need to be done in
these communities and and many people
whether it be the government or
non-profits or or others need to play
their their their role even The Rebirth
of Detroit I mentioned what we've done
from an investment standpoint which I
think has been helpful I mentioned What
You Know Dan Gilbert did in terms of
really going all in on investing in
Detroit which has been super helpful uh
also the the leadership of Foundations
like the kresky foundation was catalytic
the leadership of the governor and the
mayor was yeah it requires everybody to
do their part it I'm just focusing on
one sliver of it which I think is an
important and catalytic sliver which is
creating more jobs and more economic
growth and more places as I do think
that's one way at least I can contribute
to trying to knit together a very
divided country and giving the country
at the best possible shot of continuing
to be the most Innovative
entrepreneurial nation in the world even
as we're seeing the globalization of
Entrepreneurship and uh and and uh
there's reasons to be concerned that
maybe this next 250 years won't be as
strong as the last 250 years but rather
than just sit back and and complain
about it or worry about it I figured
I'll do at least my part to do something
about it and for me that's uh focused on
on Rise of the rest well you're doing
more than just about anyone and and you
say in your book as a fitting Capstone
uh America's 250th birthday is going to
be in 2026. now we're going to be
celebrating in style or our we not
that's what we got to do let's stay
optimistic Andrew stay optimistic now
I've been working on that as I start the
book with that reference and end the
book with that reference because I I I'm
partly pulled into that because I am the
chair of the Smithsonian we have you
know 19 museums on the National Mall Air
and Space American history natural
history and so forth and I was at the
200th birthday of the country when I was
still a teenager that's when the air and
space museum opened uh and uh in 1976
um and I remember it and so I want to
make sure the 250th uh is equally
memorable for the the teenagers who
might be there in in four years and is a
is an opportunity for the Smithsonian to
lean in the future and and you know
reach more people in more places we have
a whole strategy virtual Smithsonian
strategy around trying to be in every
home in every classroom and also we use
this 250th birthday as a opportunity to
renew that spirit that can do pioneering
you know kind of spirit that's made
America America and so that's that's uh
you know what I'll work on towards uh
that anniversary in in four years and
and some of that obviously ties in with
what we've been talking about here with
with rise rest hopefully we have at
least a little bit more inclusive
Innovation economy when we turn 250 and
we're on the path to really help more
people in more places be part of the
future and really live the American
dream 250 years young that sounds like a
party I gotta be there congratulations
Steve on your work first and foremost on
a great book rise of the rest how
entrepreneurs and surprising places are
building the new American dream uh
entrepreneurs need a champion and you
are one of the or the very best that
America has thank you very very much my
friend for everything you do please say
hey to Gene uh and the team for me
I will do that thank you thank you for
giving us the opportunity to talk about
the the book and for all you've done
over the past decade and look forward to
continuing to work with you as we both
do our part to make sure that this next
chapter for America is a bright one
yeah man let's race towards this uh 2026
celebration oh
God
more then yeah hopefully I'll see you
before then thanks so much Steve all
right thanks